des addictions et des débordements à
desta Jérôme Goulon est là bonsoir
bonsoir est-ce que vous avez écouté
Yanis hier soir dans TPMP Yanis qui
d'exliquer évidemment on lui a posé la
question enfin lui a posé la question et
tout le monde voulait savoir pourquoi
pourquoi il n'était pas sur cette
nouvelle saison de la starac il a
reconnu qu'il avait eu quelques petits
débordement la saison précédente je
buvais effectivement avant les primes
dans ma loge j'avais du champagne et je
buvais pendant les primes dans mon mug
j'avais du champagne et je buvais après
les prime c'est vrai je l'ai dit je l'ai
reconnu voilà et malheureusement ce qui
se passait c'est que du coup je devenais
fragile et le mix de tout ça plus la
fatigue plus la pression faisait que mes
angoisses mes crises angoisses venaient
et devenaient de plus en plus régulière
et seulement le problème c'est que si à
la rigueur j'avais juste fait ça mais
j'avais fermé ma gueule et que j'avais
dit à personne ça serait pass ces crème
si j'avais rien dit je seraai encore sur
la deuxème
saison est dangereux pour la santé vous
le savez évidemment voilà B bon il parle
d'abus je ne sais pas si voilà on parle
d'abus avant les coupes de champagne
pendant une émission ça existe depuis
des années pendant des années notamment
thry Ardisson luême avait ses coupes de
champagne il affiché ouvertement ses
invités avaient tout du champagne à un
moment il a arrêté de leur servir du
champagne parce que ça devenait une
cacophonie si on parle que d'alcool
Yanis Marchal c'est pas le premier cas
ni le dernier avec modération avec
modération mais effectivement parfois il
y a des des abus supplémentaires Jean
Pascal jeais avoir ton avis moi je suis
un peu je suis un peu partagé que ENF je
sais pas je je ne connais pas du tout
Yanis Marchal il a fait une très bonne
saison et cetera mais je suis je pour
moi je suis pas sûr que ce soit l'excuse
pour laquelle il est pas sur la nouvelle
saison ça nengage que moi ça va encore
jaser mais le coup de l' starx ça a été
l'euphorie et cetera
l'alcool je veux dire c'est euh si c'est
le fait d'avoir nous à notre première
mais je veux dire nous à notre première
je vais vous dire on on on va jouer
carte sur table j'ai toujours été
honnête à la télé tout le monde le sait
vous me connaissez tous comme ça je vais
vous dire moi quand jeis sorti de la
starac c'était l'euphorie c'était
incroyable on était sans exagérer les
rollingston j'ai vu dans les soirées des
saladiers de
cocaïne tout le monde avait le nez
dedans mais c'est qui je n'ai je vais
pas donner de nom il y a certaines drog
qui ont détruit certains de ma promotion
ça c'est certain il y en a quelquesuns
aujourd'hui que j'ai revu c'est c'est
terminé ce sont des zombies certains
c'est ils croient encore qu'ils vont
faire ils sont très loin ça les a tué
mais moi pour mon cas je n'i jamais
touché donc de dire ouais je bois un peu
avant je bois mais il y a un moment il
faut se dire excusez-moi mais faut avoir
des couilles de se dire j'ai une chance
je fais un boulot il faut être un peu
fort je et tout le monde n'est pas égal
de non mais je suis d'accord ouais mais
moi ça m'emmerde personnellement moi je
pense que c'est pas facile parce que tu
as vécu des émotions très intense
lorsque tu étais dans C acad 100 fois
plus importante je pense que ce qu'il a
vécu et on n pas craqué donc je me dis
il faut il y a un moment il faut pas
craquer compr promotion certains ont
craqué voilà je peux comprendre et je
neexcuse pas et c'est injustifiable mais
je peux imaginer que certains aient
envie d'avoir encore plus fort de plus
grosses émotions et c'est quoi bien
c'est les par tout simplement peut-être
je sais pas moi dans le cas de la coca
je sais pas moi j'ai jamais consommer ça
je peux vous le garantir mais il paraît
que ça donne de l'énergie est-ce que il
y a pas consommation chez les célébrités
on parle pas déjà il y a pas que des
célébrités parce que déjà en France
c'est on le voit en France la
consommation de cocaine a explosé il y a
quelques années g aujourd'hui on est
plutôt sur 60 g on le voit la drogue
c'est pas forcément propre célébrité
vous allez Porte de la Chapelle vous
avez des des gens qui sont sous l'effet
de drogue de sont de véritables zombies
c'est pas une question de célébrité
après dans le cas de Yanis effectivement
on sait pas exactement Gill ver quand
même sous-entendu qu'il y avait un
problème qui n'était pas forcément lié
qu'à l'alcool et je ne peux pas croire
une seule seconde que TF1 évince
un pour uniquement de l'alcool je n'y
crois pas je n'y crois pas c'est la
version officielle je je pense qu'il y a
eu autre chose je peux pas le prouver
j'en sais rien c'est juste une hypothèse
pour moi le problème n'est pas lié à
l'alcool mais peut-être comme Gill
Verdez l'insinuer il y a eu d'autes
d'autres choses peut-être de la drogue
je dis peut-être je n'en sa rien voilà
la drogue effectivement qui est un Frio
chez certaines célébrités c'est pour ça
qu'on voulait en parler aujourd'hui on
pense àana
effectivement on se rappelle tous de
Lana la star du loft le premier loft
cétait l'une des icônes de la
téléréalité elle était venue s'exprimer
dans PMP raconter sa sa descente aux
enfers un moment tu as vraiment plongé
dans la drogue oui tu dis un moment que
tu prenais de la drogue au petit
dééjeuné oui comme quelqu'un qui qui est
alcoolique et qui boit son verre
d'alcool le matin au réveil ben moi je
prenais de la drogue au matin au réveil
tu prenais quoi de la cocaïne c'estàdire
donc le matin au réveil tu te réveillais
je me prenais j'en prenais je prenais un
trait ouais jusqu'au soir c'est terrible
c'est terrible ce que raconte LAN je
Pascal tu VO c'est c'est triste non mais
on en parlait pendant pant REP mais moi
ça moi ça me choque pas parce que moi je
suis très dur avec tout ça c'est on sait
très bien les ravages de tout ça vous
n'avez pas besoin de prendre de la
drogue pour faire de la télé on dit les
gens de la télé ils sont tous coqués
tout c'est faux c'est partout pareil ne
touchez à mais non mais on dit ouais le
showbe c'est la C
c'est des conneries donc quand les gens
moi je prenis un TR un truc la preuve ça
serv à rien je suis désolé c'est dire
TER je
trouveon fait la télé il y a devir
d'exemplarité parce qu'il y a des jeunes
qui suivent en fait ces artistes et
enfin la drogue c'estavage on va pas Leo
la consommation de drog est strictement
interdite en France dans le cadre de
l'ANA il faut quand même resituer le
contexte elle elle a une enfance elle a
eu une jeunesse très difficile elle a
été abusé sexuellement elle a perdu la
garde de sa fille Mindy et tout ça
c'était avant qu'elle soit connue donc
déjà avant même de faire de la
télévision elle avait une fragilité et
puis elle est devenue célèbre elle a eu
beaucoup d'argent forcément ça attire
des personnes qui sont pas forcément
fréquentable et qui l'ont incité à dis
si tous ceux qui ont une enfance
difficile étai tombé dans la drogue il y
aurait un Paquier de camé en France aud'
dire pas pas Pascal dans ce qu' winter
également qui av bon qui s'était confié
aussi qui av reconnu qu' é au winter
elle avait déclaré oui je me suis drogué
alors elle elle disait oui comme tout le
monde dans ce métier c'est un cursus un
passage obligé c'est ce qu'elle a dit
elle a dit je me suis drogué comme tous
les artistes que je fréquentais à
l'époque alors tout le monde évidemment
il faut pas faire de généralité tout le
monde n'est pas drogué en revanche quand
elle dit qu'effectivement elle avait des
un entourage qui l' incitaé à ça on p à
des gens comme prince l ravit whtney
wuston effectivement elle s'est retrouvé
dans un milieu où comme le disait Jean
Pascal vous trouvez dans des soirées ou
des appartements des saladés de coke
tout le monde arrive et même si vous en
avez jamais pris bah vous avez envie
d'essayer c'était un peu entre
guillemets la drogue un peu branché on a
des aiguilles on prend de la cque donc
on est branché on est dans voilà et vous
une deè soirée une trème ouis mais
est-ce que ça existe encore ça enfin
pardon sûr ceux qui nous regardent se
posent la question les saladiers de c ça
ex bien sûr ça existe je pense en fait
que la seule chose qu'il faut se dire
c'est que si entre entre guillemets
souvent ça m'est arrivé moi dire en gros
si tu fais pas ça tu n'arriveras pas à
ça mais faut peut-être des fois avoir le
courage dei dire et ben je vais passer à
autre chose je ferai autre chose plutôt
que de se dire je vais avoir ça avec ça
et finalement regz Lana ça a rien
apportter c'est voilà c'est plutôt toi
le cas à part pardon ou ou des gens
comme moi que que que les autres parce
qui attirent effectivement tout un
milieu qui nous écout vu avec Jean-Luc
de la rue l'entourage de Jean-Luc de la
rue parce qu'on parle toujours de
Jean-Luc on parle pas de toute la sphère
qui l'entourait qui sont passes crème
voire qui ont dénoncé l'usage de la
drogue quand il est mort alors que non
seulement il faisait pire mais il le
poussait à en prendre il le poussait à
en prendre bien s je voudrais écouter
marine il faut faut rappeler pourquoi
les gens se droguent c'est pas par
plaisir c'est vraiment une anxioolyse on
est dans un milieu qui est quand même
très très exigeant le stress il est là
et on leur propose une solution de
facilité plutôt qu'aller travailler sur
soi de prendre directement de la drogue
avec un effet
immédiat c'est plus fun c'est ça le le
truc c'est pas ça il suffit qu'on soit
pas très bien entouré qu'on ait des
fragilités autour bah tout de suite on
va la faciliter on va vers la drogueou
et puis moi j'ai entendu le discours la
cocaïne ça booste les capacités
intellectuelles Ann et surtout ça coupe
l'appétit et ça évite de souvent très
maigr mais la politique les top
model tous ces gens t toutes ces sphères
qui se côtoient en prenez chez les
hommes politiques on pourrait citer des
noms et on le citera pas bien entend
pour citer des chefs d'État pas actuel
des chefs d'État passé où cétait connu
qui é ternué c'était la champ deleheure
c'était la ch Pascal franchement oh
c'était pour adoucir un peu le
débat quand il s'arrête du jour au
lendemain parce que Jean-Luc a fait ses
14000 km de rédemption c'est le seul à
les avoir fait et ben il s'est arrêté du
jour ainorgan s trouvé sevr brutalement
et c'est sauvage aussi pour le
corer point parce que
la merci beaucoup tout de suite mer
à